god bless business I'm talking about
myself
hi guys it is Wednesday here on its
craze for one several Wednesday's or oh
sure don't make me giggle every time cuz
it's both exciting and condescending I'm
gonna make time learn at you guys what
needed to be reviewed to I had
distracted by absolutely nothing I would
all meet I'm gonna ask you guys what did
you want to see reviewed today and I
feel like there's stuff on my nose okay
now you're just picking your nose on
camera picking your nose picking at my
nose there's a difference no there's not
I mean on my tumblr nasty what didn't
you want to see review today and so many
of you said frozen are just so many of
you said playlist live including the
playlist live tumblr kudos to you I
decided today I will review the movie
frozen because I actually watched it on
the plane on the way back from playlist
live and I never watch movies ever
especially on planes but the plane
didn't have internet so and I didn't
bring any other source of entertainment
because I forgot completely that planes
sometimes don't have internet because I
forgot that I'm spoiled and jaded in the
world as it is in these electronically
advanced modern times well what well
they're talking about so I watched a
movie and so many people have lost their
[ __ ] that if you go to the lost and
found there's just piles and piles of
[ __ ] they're over this film so I had
those you know expectations of us
probably not gonna be good because
everyone likes it and
everyone has an inner child especially
the lady said a pregnant out there heyo
and I feel like this is definitely a
film that makes you feel like a little
kid watching it and loving it at least I
felt that way because I caught myself
reacting to the film in a public space
without knowing that I was reacting
certain ways I caught myself doing this
throughout the whole film okay mm-hmm I
get this what how do your eyes do that
they look like ants in the face
spontaneous outbursts of songs that you
feel uncomfortable to the faces are
reminiscent of a bug's life
oh the Snowman is like Vedanti and Shrek
I get the device what a [ __ ] so it's
the other one don't do this to me
kiss kiss kiss kiss kiss
Oh two kisses this is a really good song
yeah I got into it maybe because I had a
few vodka sodas but so I rate frozen
four and a half what is the rating
system I rate frozen four and a half no
I don't want to give it five because
that snowman creature
I feel like you got touched weird as a
child and that's why so sweet just
kidding just kidding just kidding but I
don't know the backstory also I just
also thank you for all your wonderful
well wishes of me not feeling well you
guys are very nice but also let it go
let it go I mean it I'm gonna buy that
song right now